>> Sandra: DOES FAMILIES
ENJOYING A FLICK OUTSIDE NOW.
PHIL KEATING, THANKS FOR THAT
STORY.
>> Ed: AMID THOSE GROWING
PROTESTS IN VARIOUS STATES
AGAINST STAY-AT-HOME ORDERS, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS WEIGHING IN
ON THE RESTRICTIONS STEMMING
FROM THE PANDEMIC.
>> WE LISTEN CAREFULLY TO A
NUMBER OF THESE RULES BEING PUT
INTO PLACE AND AS ONE GOES TOO
FAR WE INITIALLY TRIED TO JUMP
ON THE GOVERNORS TO ROLL THEM
BACK, AND WE WILL FILE A
STATEMENT OF INTEREST AND SIDE
WITH THE PLAINTIFFS.
AS THESE THINGS EMERGE IN THE
STATES WE WILL TAKE A LOOK AT
THEM.
>> JOINING US NOW IS IAN PRYOR.
WE APPRECIATE YOU COMING IN.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL MILLION TO
WILLIAM BARR WEIGHING IN THERE
AND CHRIS WALLACE WAS ON LAST
HOUR SAYING HE BELIEVED THAT IT
WAS SHAKY LEGAL GROUND OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WAS ON AND HE
DIDN’T QUITE UNDERSTAND WHY HE
WAS WEIGHING IN AT ALL.
HOW DO YOU ANSWER THAT?
>> I THINK WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS DOING HERE
IS HE IS NOT NECESSARILY ANY ONE
THING IS ONEROUS OR NOT, BUT
THAT WE ARE IN SORT OF TIMES
THAT WE HAVE NOT SEEN PROBABLY
SINCE WORLD WAR II WHERE A LOT
OF THESE RESTRICTIONS ARE
CERTAINLY GOING TO BE BURDENED
ON CIVIL RIGHTS.
NOTJUST BECAUSE SOMETHING IS A
BURDEN ON CIVIL RIGHTS DOESN’T
MEAN IT’S UNCONSTITUTIONAL, AND
JUST BECAUSE THE STATE IS DOING
SOMETHING TO PROTECT PEOPLE
DOESN’T MEAN IT IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
SO HE’S SAYING I WILL LOOK AT
THESE RESTRICTIONS AND IF
SOMETHING STARTS TO GO OVER WHAT
WE THINK IS A CONSTITUTIONAL
LINE, WE WILL BEGIN TO TALK
ABOUT MUNICIPALITY OR THE STATE.
IF THAT DOESN’T WORK AND SOMEONE
BRINGS A LAWSUIT THEN WE WILL
LOOK AT WEIGHING IN.
>> Ed: I WONDER IF HE’S TIPPED
AA HAS HAND A BIT, IN TERMS OF
THE PENDULUM AND HOW IT SWINGING
BECAUSE HE SAID IT WAS CLOSE TO
THIS.
>> THE IDEA THAT YOU HAVE TO SAY
IN YOUR HOUSE IS DISTURBINGLY
CLOSE TO HOUSE ARREST.
NOT SAYING IT WASN’T JUSTIFIED
OR IN SOME PLACES IT MIGHT STILL
BE JUSTIFIED BUT IT’S VERY
ONEROUS AS IT IS SHUTTING DOWN
YOUR LIVELIHOOD.
>> Ed: THIS IS SOMETHING WE
SING WITH PROTESTS AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
BUT TO SAY IT’S CLOSE TO HOUSE
ARREST WHEN THE PRESIDENT AND
WHITE HOUSE WOULD SAVE MAY BE
RELUCTANTLY, BUT THEY HAD TO DO
BECAUSE IT WAS A HEALTH CRISIS.
>> THIS IS INTERESTING.
THE STORY SHOULD BE USED IN
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW CLASSES
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY FOR THE
NEXT 50 YEARS.
BUT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT IS WHEN
WE HAVE THINGS LIKE HOUSE
ARREST, IS THAT THE MOST
NARROWLY TAILORED SOLUTION?
THAT’S THE CONSTITUTIONAL TEST.
IN SOME CASES IT MAY BE AND
THAT’S WHAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WAS SAYING.
IN SOME CASES PERHAPS NOT
LEAVING HER HOUSE IS THE MOST
NARROWLY TAILORED SOLUTION WE
CAN GET TO PREVENTING THE SPREAD
OF CORONAVIRUS WHICH IS A
COMPELLING GOVERNMENT INTEREST.
SO MAYBE IN A PLACE, A HIGHLY
DENSE PLACE WHERE PEOPLE ARE
LEAVING THEIR HOUSE, IT’S NOT
SUCH A GREAT THING.
BUT IF YOU ARE IN WYOMING OR A
RURAL AREA, IS THAT THE MOST
NARROWLY TAILORED SOLUTION TO
THIS COMPELLING GOVERNMENT
INTEREST?
I THINK THAT’S WHERE YOU HAVE TO
LOOK AT IT.
YOU HAVE TO SEE, IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT’S ACTUALLY
HELPING THE SITUATION OR, IS IT
TOO BROAD IN ALLOCATION?
IN MANY CHANCES IT COULD BE
DEPENDING ON THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
>> IT DEPENDS ON WHETHER IT’S
TOO BROAD.
MAYBE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAD A
POINT BECAUSE AS WE REPORTED A
MOMENT AGO, THE MICHIGAN
GOVERNOR UNDER PRESSURE IS NOW
SAYING MAYBE SOME OF IT WENT TOO
FAR AND SHE’S PULLING BACK.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND PERHAPS, WHAT HE DID
EFFECTIVELY WAS KINCAID A
WARNING THAT EVERY STATE
GOVERNMENT OR CITY AND TOWN
REALLY NEEDS TO LOOK AT THESE
RESTRICTIONS AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY PASS CONSTITUTIONAL MUSTER.
I’M SURE THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOES NOT WANT TO GET
INVOLVED IN THIS CASE OR
INTERVENE IN LAWSUITS BUT THE
FACT IS THEY HAVE JOB TO PROTECT